invité de notre journal une autre
chanteuse qui elle revient de tourner et
non pas d'angleterre mais de belgique et
de suisse avant un récital de cinq jours
à la salle pleyel à paris france gall
bonsoir dans ce cadre nettement plus
intimiste que le palais omnisports de
bercy vous allez interpréter pour la
première fois sur scène certaines
chansons de michel berger composait pour
françoise hardy pour johnny hallyday ou
encore pour fabienne thibeault avant de
vous retrouver tout de suite un petit
aperçu des répétitions à pleyel
holmes
son talon
barré la rue
à
les affiches dans les rues
ballon jours
sassus
on est appelés
et pour toujours
maman
harish objets me pencher pour benoît
répétition
bonsoir france gall vous espériez
beaucoup avec michel berger chanter à
pleyel ça s'est jamais fait en fait
c'est un peu c'est un peu un rêve qui se
réalise pour vous à partir de demain
c'est une grande chance oui c'est vrai
que c'est une salle merveilleuse qui
était fermée depuis presque vingt ans à
la musique de notre époque donc en fait
on a toujours eu envie de la faire mais
tout le monde a eu envie de la faire
donc voilà je pense que tout le monde va
la faire maintenant parce que c'est une
vraie salle fait pour la musique c'est
une salle beaucoup plus intimiste que
bercy c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et pour l'autre le choix c'est un
jugement et puis au moment où bercy va y
avait il faut bien le dire un contexte
psychologique très difficile oui elles
ont franchi étrangers vous aviez parlé
de votre concert là maintenant c'est une
sorte de renaissance pour vous oui on
peut dire ça et puis on peut dire je
pense qu'il fallait que je passe par ce
spectacle de bercy qui était vraiment un
spectacle très particulier pour pouvoir
enfin faire ce que les choses en plus
grande liberté et sans avoir jeudi a pas
d'obligation mais bon j'étais très
triste pour bercy là j'ai envie d'être
plus joyeuse et de faire des choses qui
correspond plus maintenant et voilà donc
c'est assez c'est un spectacle
complètement différent c'est pas bercy
en pétillent à ça n'a rien à voir il ne
reste rien au programme lui-même
même le programme il est commandé dre
des chansons et composé par michel
berger ou donc à wil oui mais certaines
que vous n'aviez jamais interprété sur
scène
oui parce que parce que bon je me fais
vraiment plaisir en faisant ce spectacle
c'est la première fois que j'ai pensé
d'abord à moi avant de penser au public
les gens qui viendront me voir mais en
revanche en faisant ces trois chansons
que j'ai jamais chanté mais que m
c'est la raison pour laquelle je les
fais je sais qu'il les aime ces chansons
donc voilà c'est un échange la scène
c'est rien d'autre que ça vous disais
tout à l'heure on change tout vu par
rapport à bercy nouveau groupe nouvel
habillage musical nouvion de tennis le
rompit à l'ego ce beau et les garçons
qui chante et qui danse des nouveaux
musiciens et puis on
on a essayé de faire du beau avec très
peu de choses très peu de projecteur par
exemple c'est plus difficile de faire un
beau spectacle elle prête peu de
projecteur plutôt qu'avait dit bill ça
oblige à se creuser un peu plus donc en
fait on sait tous ce creuset quoi c'est
tombé et ai travaillé vous vous avez
vous revenez de belgique de brigil ce
16e passé ça s'est très bien passé et
paris est une étape c'est vrai j'ai pas
pensé à faire paris je voulais faire une
tournée je voulais chanter sur scène à
propos des tables d'adamou pourquoi
cette envie de partir aux états unis
vous ne sentez pu bien en france à paris
non j'étais tesla france
non c'est parce qu'il faut jeu il faut
que mes enfants apprennent la langue
américaine anglaise et qui fait meilleur
états unis
côté climat est plus en plus mon fils a
toujours eu envie d'être américain et
puis là-bas je vais pouvoir faire de la
musique parce que c'est vraiment un pays
pour faire de la musique
donc je vais vous faire l'utile et
l'agréable et partir quelques mois mais
les avions maintenant tout ça ok mais
pas vraiment merci beaucoup france gall
donc je rappelle pleyel pour cinq soirs
à partir de demain et ensuite une
tournée dans les principales villes de
france
voilà avant lui avant le grand départ
provisoire aux états unis